primero que todo Qué significa la
continuidad la posible continuidad de
shinjin que para occidente que está cada
vez más preocupado por esa cercanía de
Beijing con Moscú Buenos días Daniela
para ti y para todos Muchísimas gracias
por la invitación Bueno yo pienso que
esto es parte de lo que ha sido el
proyecto político contundente de esta
primera década un enfoque profundo y
personal de lo que él quiere de lo que
va a hacer esta china moderna Sí él ha
implementado una visión una visión y una
estrategia para un país moderno Claro
sin abandonar obviamente parte de esa
orientación política comunista entonces
vemos que en esta reunión y en esta
asamblea él prácticamente tiene el apoyo
de los tres mil delegados donde hacen un
análisis de lo que han sido estos
primeros diez años de gobierno del
presidente y obviamente también tiene la
potestad de elegir unos nuevos cargos de
un acompañamiento precisamente
político entonces Esto va a destacar
precisamente que el gobierno sufre
algunos cambios y también ha creado un
culto al liderazgo de la personalidad
con la que obviamente desde el 2013
viene
creciendo Y colocando a China como un
gigante asiático en el mundo Bueno uno
de los mensajes más importantes de hoy
es el incremento del gasto militar y la
advertencia de que no van a permitir la
independencia de Taiwán Qué significa
Qué mensaje le están dando a su pueblo
Bueno por el tema digamos del
crecimiento económico básicamente va a
ser progresivo el presidente no la tiene
fácil porque todos sabemos que hay una
desaceleración mundial la crisis
inmobiliaria y buenas tensiones
geopolíticas hace que china en este
tiempo en estos años más o menos crezca
ante un cinco a un cinco punto cinco por
ciento y eso obviamente pues no es muy
bueno para china que venía antes de la
pandemia en un crecimiento progresivo
con el tema de Taiwán digamos va a ser
también complejo porque ellos sabe china
sabe que Taiwán tiene un apoyo muy
grande de Estados Unidos y efectivamente
lo que se ve a partir de esa molestia
esa visita que tuvo Nancy pelotti el año
pasado a Taiwán Ha logrado como resarcir
como esa cierta injerencia y por eso el
en la en el diálogo o en el lo que pasó
hoy hablan ellos de que no puede haber
en una intromisión precisamente a Taiwán
por eso Ellos hablan de luchar contra la
secesión y no la intromisión y Esto va a
permitir que efectivamente china haya
hecho un aumento en un gasto de defensa
el año pasado fue el siete punto uno
este año es del Siete punto dos y
también está preparando su ejército para
combate capacidad militares para
efectivamente lograr las tareas que el
partido les va a encomendar Así que lo
que vemos es que hay un una china
comprometida con una política exterior
independiente y de paz pero también
vemos que también hay una parte de
querer blindar prácticamente el tema de
una sola China